alright this is step five of how to
solve a Rubik's Cube at this point you
should already have a cross on the top
in yellow and you should also have two
completed bottom layers that were done
in the last four steps so what we need
to do now is we need to just check how
many additional corners we have next to
this yellow cross in my case I have zero
but you might have one or you might even
have two three is not a possibility so
depending on how many you have there are
certain ways to hold the cube before you
perform the algorithm the algorithm in
this case is right clockwise top
clockwise right counter clockwise top
clockwise right clockwise top 180 and
right counterclockwise so in my case I
have 0 extra corner pieces next to the
yellow cross so as I diagrammed here if
you have no corner pieces on the top you
need to place a yellow piece on the top
layer in the upper left of the left face
and the upper right of the left face so
in my case that would look like so and
then you could perform that move so
let's go ahead and do that so the move I
would like to perform is right clockwise
top clockwise right counter clockwise
top clockwise right clockwise top 180
and right counter clockwise
now what this gives us is it gives us
one additional corner next to this
yellow cross so if you look at the
diagram if you have one corner top piece
you are to place it in the bottom-left
of the top face so I would be holding it
like this and this would now be my front
face this is the top
this is the right so you have to
position it like this so after you
position it like that then you can again
perform the same move so that move is
right clockwise top clockwise right
counter clockwise top clockwise right
clockwise top 180 and right counter
clockwise now as you can see in my case
that completes the top layer now you
have all yellow on top that doesn't
finish the cube though you still have to
position the remaining edge pieces and
corner pieces of the top layer so the
one case that I didn't go over is the
case where you have two top corner
pieces next to the yellow cross and for
all the cases there are certain
different ways that this can look you
can have two ones that look on top like
this and you have a yellow piece here
now you always have to place the yellow
corner piece on the front face in the
upper left so I have used I'm using my
old cube as a demonstration so this is
in this case it is this case so what you
have to do is you have to place the
yellow corner piece in the upper left of
the front face now you might be holding
it like this all you have to do is
basically just rotate the cube until you
have a piece that matches where you need
to put it which is in the upper left of
the front face then you can go ahead and
perform that same move so I'm going to
do that move again so once it's here
then you could perform that move this is
now the front face so it is right
clockwise top clockwise right counter
clockwise top clockwise right clock
eyes top 180 and right counterclockwise
now you see what that gives you is the
one piece next to the cross so it is
already positioned as you can see
there's already positioned as it should
be when you're performing the algorithm
so all you have to do is just do the
move enough another time so if we do the
move another time right clockwise top
clockwise right counter clockwise top
clockwise right clockwise top 180 and
right back down we get another instance
where there is one corner piece next to
the cross but as you'll see it's in the
upper right and we don't want it there
we want to in the lower left so all we
have to do is just turn the cube until
we have that piece there and you'll
notice that there is a yellow piece in
the upper right of the front face if you
have a case where there is one
additional corner piece next next to the
cross and you also have on the front
face a yellow piece in the upper right
then you'll know that by performing that
algorithm one time it will complete the
top layer that's called this soon su and
E so if we perform that move one more
time right clockwise top clockwise right
counter clockwise top clockwise right
clockwise top 180 and right
counterclockwise that completes the top
layer the next step is going to be
positioning the corner pieces of the top
layer